well catholic charities of southern
nevada depends on volunteers to carry
out their mission of serving southern
nevada and like other places the
non-profit had to pause its volunteer
program during the pandemic but they're
back hector mejia is live near owens and
las vegas boulevard with a look at the
volunteer opportunities that you might
be interested in
good morning hector
hey there sherry good morning yeah
volunteers are finally back you know
they had to make some adjustments over
the last year and a half without the
volunteers but now that they are
returning it'll help them kind of you
know run more of a smoother operation
although they never stopped helping
people joining us live we have sue
curlin here with the food pantry good
morning thanks for having us so thank
you for coming thanks for having us so
first off for those who are watching it
may feel a little shy seeking help
what's your message out there to them it
is a very easy process you just come in
you bring a state id or clarity card
proof of address we get you signed up in
10 minutes we are here to help we treat
everybody with dignity and respect come
down and get your food our motto is keep
a roof over your head keep your
utilities on we'll make sure you have
food on the table for your family and
the need during this pandemic is still
there strong oh yes it's been going
strong food insecurity has always been
an issue but with the pandemic we see a
different demographic of client we see
clients that never had to reach out for
help before but they lost their job or
they have illness and they needed to
seek help so they come to us and we make
sure they're taken care of a lot of
people still seeing rough times tell us
about the food pantry here what you guys
have to offer and
when are you guys open we're open monday
through friday 8 a.m to 10 p.m and we
offer
food to insecure food insecure families
we're giving about 100 pounds of food
this month please come down we have tons
of food
and on that note what are some of the
popular items you guys see out here box
cereal
can protein peanut butter and jelly
pasta oatmeal all the staples they're
the most popular making me hungry this
early and for a box cereal we have a
whole bunch of options from rice
krispies cinnamon toast crunch
and a whole lot a lot of others oh yeah
our clients love it we um get donations
every day we accept donations monday
through friday 8 a.m to 3 p.m the
community has really come together
during the pandemic and made sure we had
tons of donations who were able to serve
our clients all right so how can we keep
serving people in terms of volunteer
opportunities we have information on the
screen with the address and website but
tell us you know briefly volunteer
opportunities
come on in we need a lot of help we need
help stocking shelves we need help
preparing boxes preparing our usda bags
and just overall general customer
service making sure it's a serving
community lastly requirements to become
a volunteer very easy you just go to the
website fill out a form and somebody
from the volunteer department will get
back to you quickly sue thank you for
having us so early in the morning so
we'll be talking with one of the
volunteers who is actually coming back
that's still ahead of the next half hour
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you guys all right
hector thank you very much